the following is a conversation with dan
gable from two years ago
i did not previously publish this
conversation as part of this podcast
but as a separate thing and as a result
it did not receive many listens
let me be honest and say that while i
usually don't care about how many
listens reviews something gets
in this one case i feel like i've failed
one of my heroes
i feel i didn't properly introduce a
truly special human being
to an audience that might find him as
inspiring as i did
dan gable is one of the greatest olympic
athletes of all time
bigger than records and medals to many
like myself
he's a symbol of guts spirit mental
toughness
and relentless hard work as a wrestler
he was undefeated in high school
undefeated in college until his very
last match
and having lost that match he found
another level
and became a world champion and an
olympic champion
and most importantly he did so perfectly
dominating his opponents
he did not surrender a single point at
the 1972 olympic games
as a coach he led the iowa hawkeyes to
15 national titles
and 25 consecutive big ten championships
he coached 152 all-americans
45 national champions 106 big ten
champions
and 12 olympians including eight
medalists
he's the author of several books
including wrestling life
1 and 2 and coaching wrestling
successfully
quick mention of our sponsors trial labs
a machine learning company
expressvpn grammarly writing helper tool
and simply save home security so the
choice
is ai privacy grammar or safety
choose wisely my friends and if you wish
click the sponsor links below to get a
discount and to support this podcast
as a side note let me say that i spent a
few days in iowa
and got to attend a wrestling duel meet
in the historic carver hawkeye arena
part of me wanted to stay in iowa
forever to drill takedowns
to start a family to live life simply
wrestling is one of the pure sports both
beautiful
and brutal where both mental toughness
and technical mastery
of the highest form are rewarded with
victory
and everything else is punished with
defeat and every such loss weighs heavy
on the minds of anyone who has ever
stepped on the wrestling mat
including myself the same is true for
one of the greatest wrestlers in history
of the sport
the man who graciously welcomed me into
his home for this conversation
the legend dan gable if you enjoy this
thing
subscribe on youtube review it on apple
podcast
follow on spotify support on patreon or
connect with me on twitter
lex friedman and now here's my
conversation
with dan gable you're persistent i love
that because you've been trying to get
me on this podcast for
a long time and until i saw you
on another podcast and you said you were
russian
did i call you back then it was over
because russia to me you know is
leading the world in wrestling almost
every year
what's the difference between american
wrestling and russian wrestling he
showed me this painting
well it's mit it's science it's science
you know and
they they really study the sport they're
really good technically they're really
really good in strategy they don't
really push
like the real toughness they don't push
like uh conditioning right and so
americans we need what they have
russians need what we have
and if when they when you get to two
together and for me
why i could beat the russians is because
i went their way a little bit but i i
kept my toughness
but you're known you're you're known for
your toughness
yeah but i wasn't known for my art i
wasn't known for my science
so when did you become a bit of an
artist it took a loss
delario most people thought i was
already an artist just because i won 181
straight
dominance in seven years and not just
winning but you know kind of
punishing people yes and from from that
point of view yeah it might have been
pretty good but i had a long ways to go
yet
and i didn't really realize that or i
should have
i should say i didn't really know how to
get it out of me
until i had a loss and then i realized i
gotta buckle down
learn some of that science become more
of an artist how do you become an artist
so
that the russian way has this
drilling technique thousands of reps
how do you think you work on the science
the art part
you got to study the best in the world
i think dave schultz was our guy in
america
that probably showed us that
being artistic you needed that and he
studied it he went over there as a high
schooler and wrestled in some major
tournaments over there
and he saw their ways
he used that russian science and then he
was already an american
and he saw what how i trained athletes
he saw what i did in the olympics
saw what other people how he held up and
he applied that as well
but i'd have to say he was more the
artistic type he was more of a russian
than an american when it came to uh uh
wrestling
you've coached 45 national champions 106
big ten champions
and eight olympic medalists which is
incredible
what is a common thread between them
and what are maybe some of the
fundamental differences
i think the common thread is that
they all had one of those two avenues
that we talked already
and because we intertwined them
so in a russian wrestling room they got
the same people
most the time in an american wrestling
room we had the same people
but when i was out recruiting at first i
recruited just
attitude but i needed more than that
i needed some genetics in that wrestling
room
to actually that hard work people
you know they could look and see wow
that execution that's unbelievable
but yet i can beat that guy after the
first minute
so you think you think uh the art the
the technique is genetics you're born
with it
you think it's not i think your pop and
your
you know your ability to move timing and
timing and
your quickness and your strength you
know the russians
they usually picked out
the people that can go into that sport
that was the old-fashioned sports school
but it's it's mostly like when you see
when you walk into a
russian wrestling room you see him
hitting skills
techniques you know you don't see them
banging against each other that much
but then when practice is over you might
not see a bunch of sprints
you might see them walk over to the uh
the ropes
and they drop down from the ceiling and
they'll jump up and
climb a rope boom boom boom and then
they come down
and then they don't jump right back on
they have three or four other guys go
and then they jump back on whereas i
probably made my guys climb them get
right back down climb them right back
again
but i also realized
that i had to have a mix of that what
was the role what was your role
i mean those guys looked up and dan
gable and
what was the role in helping these
athletes become their best these
national champions we had to first of
all prove that you were
knew what you were doing in terms of
technique or in terms of
everything everything they just you had
to be the first guy there and the last
guy to leave and you had to be the most
dedicated guy
even though they were the ones that's
trying to win the championships
uh you had to prove that you were going
to work just as hard as they were as a
coach
and what does that look like what so you
can see it when you you know when you
see it
well you you're there ahead of them yeah
and you're there
after they leave you know it's that's
it's that simple
i'm picking up after them and you're
analyzing them
you out work them you out work them and
you out thank them
and so you know use that type of
strategy and over time
when you prove it works because
some of my kids that were the best kids
in the world
really shouldn't have been a wrestler
i mean they weren't very coordinated
yeah but they work so hard to develop
themselves
what was your role in that process i
mean that means pushing kids to their
limit if if you're not going but you
can't push kids to their limit
and even when you push them to their
limit that's not their limit
because their limits above and beyond
that right i mean yeah
coaches sometimes accidentally don't
they lose kids
yeah because of the heat because of hard
work and all that
and you gotta you gotta know where to
when to back off
you got to read your athletes and by
that i mean
you got to know them pretty well every
once in a while you make a little bit of
mistake but if you don't react right on
that mistake before it gets too far
then it's going to be a casualty and i
don't mean somebody dying
necessarily but maybe something that
could turn them off
or maybe something that can run them
away or maybe something that
wow that was close i maybe shouldn't
have pushed him that far
so you really have to be very educated
and
it's not just what you know is what you
know about them
and i'm not talking about the team i'm
talking about each guy individuals yeah
each person on the team and you you know
it how you see it now you know how
because
you're the first one there and you're
the last one to leave and and you set in
the uh
environment with them you're there for
in the morning for practice sometimes
you're there in the afternoon for two or
three hours
after practice you might have a a hot
room or
you might have a sauna or a steam or a
whirlpool and you get in there with them
and you listen you know you're not just
feeding out
information you do that but you're
taking in a lot of that
too and i'm telling you when you get in
an atmosphere that
they're relaxed and they feel
comfortable it's like a massage
and that's after practice in one of
those areas that
people are around you you learn a lot i
mean you got a lot to learn as a coach
and when you get in that atmosphere when
all of a sudden you feel like
very comfortable words start flowing
and when those words flow
you take them in as a coach and there's
something
probably going to be said that you can
do and act upon
that's going to help certain situations
i've saved a couple kids lives for sure
that we're on the brink
you know sometimes performance is at
such a high level in a
high level atmosphere
that life and death is actually involved
and i don't mean pushing a kid to where
he just dies but i mean he might
feel himself as a failure then he may go
home and take his own life
yeah i mean but that's part of it you're
putting so much heart
so much blood and heart and sweat and
every your whole meaning of life becomes
winning so and sometimes it's so hard
to lose within that context so if if in
your i think the first
wrestling life you wrote about chad
zappato
who lost i mean incredible wrestler
but lost in three finals in the
nationals and
has this tattoo of a uh hawk clawing out
the human heart yeah
so what lessons is there any lessons
from
the incredible wrestling he's done but
also the incredible suffering that he
went through
on himself yeah again you like that word
suffering
which is okay okay no no no no no keep
it keep it because it fits right in
where i want yeah
i have to turn that suffering around
to where he makes him feels good about
himself
are better does not feel perfect yeah
because he did lose yeah you know and so
but you have to actually get him to
realize
that yeah he's still unique compared to
the walk of the earth
he was unbelievably unique right at the
top just
a little bit short of but because it was
you know he felt the suffering you now
have to go about and change that
and put it into good will some way and
because he's
you really have a lot of good will you
can do a lot of goodwill
and so and it's not easy
it took him probably years
years of tattooing yeah years of
covering the tattoos
and you know he told me moved to keller
i go why are you moving to california
because he was here for a couple years
after his wrestling was done because he
had a good job around here and he was
i thought he was doing a good job but he
he just he said i had to
escape you know it's the same as the
wrestling tattoo i had a wrestling
terminology i have to get
i hate to say this i hate to say this i
go where are you going
he says i'm going to go to california
and i go is there any reason why you're
going to california
he says that's where everybody goes to
hide
but i said i think you're wrong there
but
you know i think what will determine
your life will be
what you do from now on you know and if
you can and he's actually turned it
around
i mean he's actually turned around you
have to discover that yourself exactly
and he went someplace that he thought
he could fit into and i think he did
and i think he's got a good job and he's
helping people and
uh he covered that tattoo with uh
feathers
uh another tattoo well in the end it's a
beautiful story
yeah it is it really is suffering and
overcoming yeah and he's
not done yet he's not done yet no he's
not done he he's
got a lot more to do so you mentioned
roger bannister
again i think in your first book
somebody you looked up to
that's the man who broke the four-minute
mile right
when everybody said it was impossible
everyone thought it was impossible
because he would die
he would die it's not human it's not
human yeah
so what well you've done your homework
for what the book or what
i don't know for me you've done your
homework yeah i know but yeah
sent sent here by putin to do research
yeah so what
lesson do you take from that story for
yourself the impossible
trying to accomplish the impossible well
the impossible is possible
it's just that simple time changes
things i mean
i mean if you look at what where the
mile time is right now
compared to that four minute mile which
when it was broke by
a couple tenths or three or four tenths
it's now broke by uh another 20 seconds
yeah i mean by 700 people yeah yeah i
mean
by tons of people and it's pretty much
the common knowledge that you got to run
a four minute mile if you're gonna go
somewhere now or
or below if you're going to win win
events at major level
you got to be able to do that and so you
can take that and you can look at what
in time history has as its
record performance and you can realize
that
that record performance is going to
change yeah
and and they don't take into all the
factors of knowledge
they don't take in all the factors of
better shoes
they don't take in all the factors of
better understanding and nutrition
i mean it's like me as an athlete
i went to practice every day in high
school for
at least my sophomore in my junior and
part of my
senior year and all of a sudden a new
rule came up
i said the rule said um before
that said oh yeah at least
most of the coaches uh you you we don't
want you drinking water at practice
yeah and and okay why
because you gotta toughen you up that's
a weakness water
and so we would go through practice i
mean and you're sweating and then you're
sweating so much that
you're almost out of sweat yeah and so
you're mostly at the end of practice
you're not even wrestling
excuse me you're you're sitting against
the wall yeah because you're tired
so then all of a sudden they say okay
go ahead drink water during practice
drink gratery during practice and all of
a sudden
at the end of practice we're still out
there competing and so
i look at my career for two and a half
years where i end with junior high too
so i got another three years where i
didn't really
wasn't able to push as good as i could
because i just
was probably under under hydrated yeah
yeah so what so
but at the individual level in terms of
the impossible
when did you first believe the thing
that maybe
probably people would laugh at you about
that you would be in the
champion well i always
visualized me being the best you
believed it in the very
forever forever yeah i was because i was
i don't think you call it a dreamer or
somebody that
i was just involved with competitive
sports at the ymca from the
from age five did you tell people that
dream that you're gonna be olympic
champion one day
you can be the best in the world i think
they knew
and the only reason why they knew
because there was something a little
different about this guy
he was uh he's not gonna stop well he
was out in the yard
yeah and he was swinging baseball bats
yeah you know at
six at seven and eight at nine and ten
and he was swinging baseball bats
so much right-handed and so much left
hand with nobody even there
throwing the ball yeah that all of a
sudden when they walked by and they
all of a sudden the grass was down to
dirt on both sides
so it's like they saw me on the yard
playing by myself sports or you know
or you get the neighborhood kids you
play a lot but if they weren't there
you know if you walked in my front room
i was hiking a ball
like i was the quarterback and i was
running not and running through the
through the furniture you know that type
stuff so
you know who who saw this guy mostly was
probably
the parents yeah and the the coaches at
the ymca level
the junior high level they saw this guy
come first and and end up last but
i wasn't that great i wasn't the fastest
guy at that time
and i wasn't the strongest guy you know
actually before i went to the olympics
when they tested me they tested
everybody
and i probably came back with one of the
highest scores but it was
it was not like the highest
person on this and this and that i was
all
high across the board straight across
the board high on every one of them
but there was always people that were
higher than genetics
but then they would go down yeah then
they would test on something else and go
back up
mine stayed high all across the board
and so i you know i
really didn't have too many flaws but i
didn't have any
things that also said that you were
going to be
unscored upon at the olympic games right
so
take me through that day if you could
1972 when you were going for the 68
kilogram
freestyle wrestling gold you scored
57 points if i'm correct and had
zero points scored on you 57
0. so maybe uh take me through
almost the details what was your routine
what was your process what was going
through your mind your thoughts of that
day
yeah first of all uh it was quite a day
because uh we weighed in every day
at that time in the morning and that and
that yeah we weighed in two hours before
the start of the competition
and so that didn't mean that you weighed
in two hours for your russell because
you didn't know whether you're gonna
wrestle right away or later on
in fact in that day i don't think i
wrestled uh until
later on in the evening so had all day
to recover but
i didn't really need it anyway because
you know it wasn't really
pulling a whole lot of weight but just
uh it was just interesting
but what was in your mind what would
what were you thinking were you nervous
were you
i was confident i was confident you knew
you were going to win the gold
yeah i knew i was going to win uh but in
reality
you're i'm not i didn't know it from a
cocky point of view i
only knew it because for the last
three and a half years i've been going
to practice
and i'd been winning every practice you
felt good and i i hardly ever lose a
takedown
and if i lost this if i somebody scored
on me
it was like when i went to bed i
couldn't sleep until i
figured it out or if i didn't figure it
out i would fall asleep
and i would be whoa i would wake up with
the answer of what i needed why i got
scored upon so maybe
now that you've won the gold can you
tell me in the practice room when
somebody took you down
how how do you take dan gable down in
the in the practice room
timing very difficult but yes somebody
could
because they were going for one move
all i wanted was one move whereas you
know if you can arrest somebody and rest
in the whole practice or half of
practice for at least 10 15 minutes
and they were maybe gonna score
if they could work it in their mind
but they knew that was going to be their
victory so in the practice room
maybe you can educate me and that when
you're going for the olympic gold
it you didn't want to allow any
takedowns so there's no such thing as
working on some kind of
weird position a weak point or something
it's important to not let down
the take down it's kind of like what
we're saying before
if something happened and somebody
scored on me in a certain way
i would go over that situation over that
situation over it again
and i would come up with an answer and
then i would actually test it
maybe i wouldn't go right back the next
day because i didn't want the guy to
you know do not have some i didn't want
him to think
that i was thinking about it all night i
didn't tell him but maybe three days
later when he wrestled again
i uh actually had it figured out because
it it he wasn't able to or
even if i was in on to take a a an
offensive move
and i got stopped and didn't score you
know i had to go back and
filter that but it wasn't something that
usually i couldn't solve right i could
usually solve it
let's go back to the olympic games so i
get up in the olympic in the morning
and i'm not sure when the weigh-ins were
but i think i was probably a pound over
uh you know and that's about a half a
kilo and 1.1 pounds
is a kilo because we went in kilograms
so what do you do with that pond you're
right
no i just i just went over to the they
had a sauna there
and i got in the sauna and the and the
funny thing was the morning of
the of the of the finals
there was there was another athlete in
the sauna
and american or no it was a european
i didn't i don't remember where she was
from not a russian
well you know what i kind of think it
was a plot
because it was a girl interesting and
she didn't have her top on
oh wow and that was pretty common
and so you know it's kind of interesting
you you think back about it
because there's some funny things that
that go on behind the scenes in olympic
games
in world games anytime when you have
country against country
and so there's some crazy stuff mine
goes on yeah did any of it affect you
did you was there anything well i almost
stayed too long in the sun
you los you lost a little bit of i lost
a little more in a pound yeah
but uh but it didn't really bother me
because i wasn't like
i wasn't like cutting a lot of weight so
so your match against the russian
the um how's your life yeah jolietf
he's went on to be a two-time world
champion a silver medalist as well
i mean this is an incredible wrestler so
what was going through your mind
uh before stepping on the mat with that
guy you've beaten a bunch of wrestlers
haven't had a point scored on you
and you're stepping on the mat against
the russian who you said was
really they picked the soviets picked to
beat you
right and i know why they picked him
because he had a great attitude
so he wasn't just the typical artist
he was a good artist he he hooked elbows
like
sad gelav and he's from that area of the
world
where they have some of those types of
moves but he was and he was a goer
but by cutting him down a weight he lost
some of that go
and i don't know if you you got to
that's a process you got to
go about scientifically yeah you know
and so you know if you don't do it as an
american
it can really hurt your performance if
you don't do it as a a russian
it can hurt your performance and they
already didn't really
do that a lot where you usually wrestle
the weight where it was more like your
weight
and so by cutting him down you know
maybe slowed his
belief down a little bit you saw it in
him the spirit was
a little bit gone when you were facing
yeah but then he came back and he won
you know rest of the matches and he was
in the round robin and he was able to go
to the finals
uh but he had lost another match
actually against in the round-robin
against the japanese so
i i think i had already gained
enough of artistic being able to finish
a match once i lost my match in college
for the last two years i took on some of
that artistic uh
work and i think that he was already
hoping to win but he was hoping to win
by
a long ways because he had to pin me or
beat me by
eight points to be able to win the gold
and
uh you know that wasn't going to happen
i mean the chances of pin is pretty good
is it hard to pin down gable versus take
down
like have you taken risks where you
could pay for them
i can't remember too many that i took
uh that would actually put me in a
danger position
i've taken risk but the risks were so
scientifically technically correct
that i wouldn't land in that danger
zone it's like if i'm going to lock up
and throw you i'm not going to throw you
to my own back
and roll you through i'm going to turn
in the air
so you're scientific about it yeah
exactly i you know he just
i learned the hard way early on there
was moves from collegiate wrestling
that you did that exposed your shoulders
which
it cost me in some early freestyle
matches against great wrestlers
but i would go back to my collegiate
escaping type moves to where i hit a
granby roll where you expose your
shoulders and you lose two points every
time
but you learn that that's not the system
but if you hadn't wrestled much
you would get exposed under maybe
a desperate situation you would hit it
so you won the gold
how did it feel i think it would have
i think the question would be how would
it feel if you lost the gold
for me because i already went through
that once
not at that highest level but the
national collegiate championship level
my senior year the larry owings law
larry owings yeah
and that didn't set well were you afraid
of that happening again
at the olympic level was that no i
really wasn't
but it was why i changed my
philosophy of training and added to
the scientific artist type and i if i
had
won that match even though i wouldn't
have felt good about it even if i
squeaked it out i wasn't feeling good
about that match
it would have affected me a little bit
but if i don't want it i would have got
over it
i mean i'm not over it now yeah i mean i
don't know why i was
doing this kind of stuff right before my
match yes
by by that i mean this kind of stuff
talking interviews oh yeah journalists
yeah and i really wasn't a good talker i
mean me and you were talking pretty good
right now except for i got a little cold
but
but uh i don't think i could say two
words hardly then
and they took takes wide world of sports
says hey just
we want you to be the introduction for
our next week's show
yeah so just say hey i'm dan gable come
watch me as i finish my career
undefeated 182.00
that's what they want me to say
everybody assumed you'd be undefeated
and i
said it i had to take it 22 times and
in the last two or three times they
wrote it out
and i read it and it still it wasn't
like i just said it
yeah i was reading it like hi i'm dan
gable
come come up you know that type of stuff
so it and he finally just closed the
book and said hey that's good enough
but i turned and it was my time to
wrestle yeah
and so you know you just you learn that
and for me it was great coaching
experience
because that's what i turned into be you
know i coached for
longer than i wrestled yes and i put out
a lot of champions but you learn
through mistakes that even in your own
career that you had made
you know it's it's a never learning
process it's an ever learning process
have you ever been afraid on the map
does fear have any role
do you think for a wrestler or it must
be
well i'm sure fear is out there and i'm
sure that was to my advantage
almost every time i'm sure in my olympic
finals as really if
he had these doubts he probably had
these doubts
and that gave gives me the the edge
and i don't know if i really ever
had fear
but obviously there was points and times
where i
didn't perform as well not many but
a few and if i look back of it
look back at it i don't think it was
that
american you know raw raw raw stuff i
think it was
probably the fear of uh not being an
artist
as much you know maybe this guy might be
better than me
uh scientifically and uh
you know you're a scientist i think that
got to me more than anything else
i i said early on that i want to
eliminate
ever having to worry about getting tired
in a match
so i kind of eliminated that so i got
rid of that point
and i do think that in wrestling that is
one of the fears
that a lot of wrestlers have actually
how they feel during the match and and
do they get are they going to get tired
and
and is it going to affect my performance
and
as a coach that really was one of the
things i tried to eliminate on all my
athletes
so there wasn't that fear factor but
that fear factor would be
put upon my opponent which would give me
an edge uh but that's not what i needed
as much
i need to just focus make sure that i
was doing the right things
and i needed my team to be focused so i
made sure that for my
mistakes as an athlete or even as a
coach sometimes
that i didn't repeat them didn't repeat
them and
if you make a mistake once and then you
can repeat it then it's like
you didn't learn anything your goal
throughout your wrestling career
as you've beautifully put was to work so
hard that you pass out
on the mat right that you would be
carried off the mat so you never
did successfully in that's one of the
ways you failed in your careers you've
never
worked so hard that you've passed out
have you ever come close
do you remember a time you've come close
you've been pushed to the limits
of exhaustion you know the question is
really a good question about
that pushing to you collapse yeah
because
i don't as a coach today i don't think i
could if i said that to my athletes
i don't know i could get in trouble
because you know it's understood isn't
it by the athletes
yeah they understand it but the outside
might not understand it
because it's almost like what do you
mean they're you push them to the point
where they go
collapse that means they may die or that
something might happen to them
and you know that's dangerous that's
dangerous we can't have our kid in that
type of atmosphere but it's something
that's
highly unlikely that's going to happen
but i'm going to tell you there's many
times
in a practice where i had pushed myself
to all of a sudden the whistle blew or
it was time to stop
and when i got up off the mat or
wherever i was at
and i needed water i need
i needed fresh air because you're
usually in a fairly small room with a
lot of guys
that the heat rises and you know it's
hard to breathe
and that i can remember and i stayed a
lot of times not by the door
the far end of the room i can remember
walking from the far end of the room
to that door and i can remember am i
going to make it the next step
am i going to make it the next step i
need air i need water i need oxygen
i need to get out of here it didn't
happen often but i can cut recount four
or five times in my career
that i pushed myself to that level where
i thought i was gonna maybe
go out but every step i was dizzy
but once i got to that door i was able
to
open it and go out yeah and grab the
water and get cold water in my face and
so no i never really was able to do that
and
i think the story is in a book where my
my daughter
pushed a collapse molly he made you
proud oh my gosh you know she didn't win
yeah but she pushed her collapse yeah
now did she suffer because of that
well she didn't get to go to the next
event because she didn't
she had to qualify but i think it
probably helped her too realizing
because she was wood in the race and she
was beating people she normally never
pushed
but she was at a new level that she had
never been before and she only needed
about
five feet to finish and it was just one
of those things that
i bet there was a lot of learning that
she did there and uh it probably
made her realize that she could be
better but she had to hold up though
so you mentioned in wrestling life that
the brand's brothers
looked up to royce alger who was known
for pushing the limits of physical
wrestling but not getting too rough
so how do you find the line between
extreme physical wrestling
but at the same time not rough wrestling
or angry wrestling
so that line between aggression tough
wrestling and
anger well i think anger would cause
less successful wrestling i think anger
would cause you to
make mistakes and actually get out of
position
because i think anger is kind of a loss
of control
and there can be a
furious type of
attack but i think if it crosses the
line to anger
then you're going to be vulnerable and
so
royce and the brands
wrestled to the edge through the edge
but when the whistle blew they stopped
and there's people that when the whistle
blows they keep going
it's like in a football game a fight
breaks out and it's after the whistles
blow
well when the whistle blew they they
backed off
so that whistle was
something that in a match
that that kind of gave them the
boundaries
but perhaps it could be a little bit of
fuel so in wrestling tough the book
that you just got from mike chapman uh
the new addition
talks about bill cole undefeated
northern iowa wrestler
and uh how he talked about
how my strength speed and ability to
think were increased tremendously
by just sitting apart from the action
prior to the match
and getting into a state of controlled
anger
so can anger trolling controlled
yeah so anger could be fuel as long as
it's controlled
right exactly you have that line one
side of the line you can have
an anger for performance and the other
side of
the line you if you go beyond that it's
not going to be for performance it's
going to be for
not performance because you're gonna
lose points it's a fine line there's
definitely a fine line
you're talking about roy selger you're
talking about tom brands you're talking
about terry brands
i mean you got world championship titles
there you got olympic championship title
there
you got a world silver medalist in uh in
uh
and roy selger and you know and that
that's
what when i talk to him about the world
silver medalist
he's haunted by that because he was
actually 20 seconds
away from winning when he got beat in
the end there but that's part of the
game
and it's i don't know whether he's
okay with it or not because he says
every after talking about things he goes
i'm okay with it now but then he keeps
talking about it
so i don't really think he's okay with
it
and i it's it's hard for him to actually
make amends
to himself when you really don't do it
i mean it's no matter what the situation
even with
the owings loss yeah it still eats
i mean yeah i'm a world champion he's
not and he wanted to be
i'm olympic champion he's not he wanted
to be one of the greatest
coaches of all time yeah yeah yeah and
so
you know so he you know it's like
why do i keep going back to it because
because you're not you don't get over
those things so royce really keeps going
back to it
even though he says he's fine and he and
but then he realizes he's really not
fine because that's just the nature of
the game and that's why
he was able to win national titles and
and make
uh world teams and and stuff like that
uh you know even if what's interesting
about him he's analyzed
all the people that he's wrestled and a
lot of them have won world and olympic
championships
and he's beaten every one of them at one
time or another and he
didn't get to that world championship
gold or a limping cold
and that i i he says it because
they did it so he show he's showing
people that
that i beaten those guys yeah
but apparently he didn't beat him at the
right time
and so it still haunts him you don't get
away from that stuff
i mean it's just like anything in life
that's
really high i mean it doesn't have to be
athletics
i mean you think i'm ever going to get
over uh
the murder of my sister and you might
not even know that
let me pause for a second please you've
talked about it you've written about it
so i hope it's okay for me to say that
your sister your older sister
on may 31 1964
was raped and murdered by a local boy
so the echoes of pain and anger from
that tragic day
do they ripple through your life still
through your wrestling through your
coaching through your the way you
when you wake up in the morning what is
that like
it can be very emotional to me under
certain circumstances
and it can be
the mood i'm in right you know it can be
maybe if i've had a mountain dew or or
maybe if i've had a gable beer
yeah yeah or or or uh
or maybe if you turn the country music
up a little bit loud
you know it emotions come out and
everybody has them in their life
it just so happens you know what brings
it out
and hopefully it's nothing that you do
to the extreme
point of to where it brings it out for
me it's not extreme
i don't have to have any of that really
i can get emotional
how did that change you as a man
what it did was realize that i was
already
pretty well developed because i was only
a sophomore
15 years old in high school and
i had parents that weren't making it and
my parents are a lot older than me
and now that we're down just to me and
my parents
and i'm going to be around the house for
another two years
and they had just lost a a daughter that
was the only
only other sibling
they weren't handling it they they were
the ones that were
suffering much more than me
even though i always look back upon one
area
that i wasn't good at was communication
at that time except inside the wrestling
room
because i had been tipped off and tipped
off what do you mean
well the neighbor boy said that
something to me about my sister
just three weeks before that that's
right that really
wasn't normal or practical
and i said nothing to nobody you
you don't is there a part of you that
blames yourself
yeah absolutely
absolutely but i'm 15 years old
and you make mistakes
uh and you don't really act on
everything
that happens in your life but i can tell
you how it affected me and
i acted a lot on anything that maybe
wasn't even of that consequence
i mean because i had four daughters and
i'm telling you when they left every
time to go somewhere in a car
or go out with someplace i always said
something to him
and they would always say dad you said
that last night
i don't care what like i love you or
like i'd be careful
i'd stay like don't be driving and
drinking or or don't be uh
in a car with somebody that's uh you
know of of the
of the same nature or you know stay out
of trouble you know don't go be
somewhere where you
you know you have i said you know how to
get out of a car if you if your car goes
into the river
you know you know i just you know i'm
always thinking ahead a little bit
just in case if something uh did happen
and i it goes back to that goes back to
that walk to school with that
with that young man that when he was
talking to me and i just
i took it and i kept it inside me and
once i found out she had been murdered
it
it took me maybe 25 to 30 minutes
and i told my dad i think i know who
killed her
and he looked at me and he just like
he slapped me actually he pushed me
against the car he didn't slide he
pushed me in his car my mom
slaps me and she was the one that
slapped me around a little bit but my
dad
he uh he he pushed me against his car
what do you mean you might know
something about this
i said dad i i don't for sure but
and i would probably all crying but and
i don't i doubt if i was crying
yet i've probably cried a lot of tears
since but
but you know i just said hey i was
walking to school
with this neighbor and i never had
walked to school with him before
and he was kind of a troubled kid and he
said something about
diane and it wasn't good
but i i didn't he goes why didn't you
say something
i said i daddy i i just boy talk you
know
so you know and so he hugged he hugged
me he hugged me he hugged me
and uh you know it it was one of these
things that
it's definitely made me
a lot of who i am because there's been a
lot of choices
and i don't i took the word choice out
of my life and i just like to say okay
do the right thing
do the thing that's that you should do
and so i don't really i don't
it's like you're going to do this or
this well what do you mean which one's
better
you know well then i'm so i don't have
that choice yeah just give me the right
way to go
and so it's not that i've been perfect
by any means but it's made a big
difference in my life
uh on how i handled my life it's
it's probably given me the opportunity
to be married for 44 years
it's just given me opportunities to uh
be better
in my life and and i you know i i want
to thank
my sister for that you know it's uh
and i think my family was ready to make
a split
because of that incident they're blaming
each other and i think that uh
i was able to help but more than that
they really liked each other but they
didn't really know it at the time
until i got out of the house two years
later
it probably was going on for a couple
years until i moved on and went to
college
then they found out they really liked
each other when they were alone
and it worked out pretty good but i
think them
being able to follow me not just through
college and olympics and worlds but my
coaching
so it's the same the same success and
factor
you know the excitement and and all
those things gave them a real purpose
and uh it gave my four daughters it gave
my wife
uh you know a real purpose to be able to
be close to
all these champions and championships
and and
and now it's because now it's like
there's a family of 22
and they're all interested in what what
we're interested in and it's going good
knock on wood
but you know it's something that when
all of a sudden you've got too much time
in your hands and you're not doing
accomplishing much
that things probably you know get off
get off track what do you think is the
role of family in wrestling
can a man do it alone and if not
where's family most important you know
you could do it alone
but why would you want to yeah i think
the chances of doing it alone are
much less than the chances of doing it
together yeah
i know they say don't bring your
profession home sometimes they say that
this might never i never got away from
my profession yeah
and you know sometimes i it's like
my house right here so when i'm
moving home and i'm not gonna have an
office
because i'm not gonna coach anymore or
i'm not gonna be an assistant athletic
director for a while
that got to do something that
gives you a little bit of a break not
you necessarily maybe the person you're
living with
and so i don't know if you looked
outside there i got a cabin right out of
my backyard you probably can't see it
right there but
what's in the cabin that's my house away
from my house it's only
30 feet from my house and it's my office
and it's my workout room it's my i got a
sauna there it's
it's a bed upstairs if i need it if i
ever uh
get too close and she says hey why don't
you go sleep in the other house
but you know he kicks me out of the bed
but get the heck out it's never happened
yeah but i do spend a lot of time out
there and uh
it's uh you know you gotta have a little
distance sometimes
and you gotta know you're gonna know
your role and so all of a sudden when
you're a guy that's been gone your whole
life from
eight o'clock in the morning until close
to 7 30 or 8 o'clock at night so 11
12 hours a day then all of a sudden
you're not gone as much
even though you still work she's trying
to slow me down now i'm doing uh
not so much like here what we're doing
right now but when i get in the car and
drive somewhere
or fly somewhere you know like just last
night i just went to bed and i hadn't
told her that
this guy called me and he wants me to uh
speak for
uh you want to build another wrestling
wants to
start another wrestlers in business
networking out in uh
delaware because we don't have any
colleges and wrestling in delaware
and so i said well you know you know
gladly that because that's my life
you know so but then all of a sudden i
i didn't say anything to my wife until
all of a sudden this morning
and i told her that i might go on the
friday the 21st of december
oh no well well i said that's not this
christmas she goes
we're celebrating christmas that weekend
early because a lot of the
family can't be i'll be here except for
that weekend yeah
and i said oh well that's not gonna work
but i
kind of didn't say anything to her first
and then well i'll tell you she
started getting a little emotional and
if i want to stay married for another
year 45 years
then i better tell those people that
i got family obligations because
uh yeah it depends what's most important
i love wrestling i love wrestling
and i want to start another west helper
start another wrestlers and business
network but there's more than one dang
gable out there well maybe not but
but but there's there's a lot of people
that are
um maybe even closer yeah
and they got big names i mean we're
we're doing pretty well right now i mean
we got first two years ago and we got
second this year uh and then we got the
women's freestyles doing good in
wrestling
we got to work a little bit on our greco
yet but
but they are working on it but our men's
freestyle team right
now are are excellent
and you know and uh the key for them
is to get them all on the same page
instead of just have new highlights and
by that i'm saying
who look you look and see who won this
year well the three guys that have never
won before won this year we had three
world champions
our two past world champions
didn't win this year i mean they they
did okay you know
they got medals yeah deborah's win no he
did not
he got third oh that's right he got
bronze yeah and inside
got i mean um snyder got second so
those two are our main guys you know so
the three new guys that came through
were guys that hadn't won world gold in
fact two of them have never made a world
team before
and so when we have three world
champions this year but we needed
all five of them to come through to win
the uh the championships
and so the key really is getting them
all
to do the same at the same time year in
and year out
and not just uh based on okay
uh burl's got beat this year so he'll
win next year
it's got to be every year if you're
capable of doing that and that's what
the coaching staff has to do
it's kind of funny that i do have a lot
of influence actually on the coaching
staffs right now at the usa level
because the
the women's freestyle guy is uh is terry
steiner and he wrestled for me he was a
national champion he's got a twin
brother
that's at uh fresno state and then billy
zaddick
is the uh freestyle coach and he
wrestled for the hawkeyes back in uh
the early days and uh he was the
national champion so
we got a lot of uh former gable
influence on there but
but it's got deep roots in there in 2013
the international olympic committee ioc
voted wrestling out of the olympics
so a lot of folks know about this the
absurdity of it
and so on but in a big picture you can
step back now it's five years later what
did you learn from
that experience well first of all
did it surprise me yeah
but did it really surprise me no
you gotta run you gotta have people
running
the organization that are
top-notch if you take anything for
granted
and you're not the person of authority
somebody can
kick you out and even though
we had a lot of authority because we're
wrestling we're the one of the first
sports in the
olympics ever and that we
uh think that you know
we're in 180 some countries and uh
some of the number one countries in the
world
that are politically strong have the
sport
you know we thought we were okay but
then you got to look and see who's
running the ilc
the ioc the international olympic
committee yeah
and then you got to see that in
wrestling we don't have anybody in there
i mean that shocked me we've never had
anybody
on the ilc from wrestling yeah you know
why
because we didn't have to
but yes that's wrong you have to and
if you don't have somebody looking out
for you
right within the structure then it's
pretty easy
people turn their head yeah but all it
took
was the statement you guys are kicked
out of the olympics
you guys are done everybody came
together i think well yeah i mean it's
the first time in ever
in history that probably all this
competitive people
that were working for their own agenda
turn that agenda to the sport
and that so that made a big difference
and we got a lot done
in fact in america
there was several people that were
really out there that we didn't know
about until this point in time
and when they came aboard now they're
still aboard
that doesn't mean we're doing everything
perfect because just because we got
voted back in before we even got kicked
out really
that doesn't mean we're by any means
safe
we have to do some of the things that
i'm talking about or some of the things
that
we didn't do before we can't fall right
back into the same mess
yes and so our leadership got changed
and it's better but it's got to stay
better
but there are things that we could still
be
doing to make sure that we don't
have situations like this happen i'll
tell you when i first learned about it
i was like i broke down and wept
yeah again it's like every once in a
while i'll break down and
and and cry about my sister
yeah or i'll break down i don't know if
i cry about losing to owings but
i'd probably get more determined but
that's kind of uh
you have to go back and and think about
those moments when you heard when i
heard that moment and i
i said i it just overcame me it was like
four o'clock 4 4 30 in the morning
when i heard about it and uh my wife had
been been up looking at the internet and
she she woke me up i thought she was
joking
but i jumped out of bed really quick
when she said that i knew she was
serious
and i started making phone calls right
then
to find out if it was true and when i
found out was true you know it was just
like devastating
you know and it was one of these things
that
it's a nightmare and
but you don't let it happen again it's
that simple yeah and you keep getting
stronger
yeah and uh if people haven't read they
should read the loss of dan gable by ray
thompson the espn article
that kind of in this very beautiful
poetic way
ties together uh all the losses of dan
gable
the losing your sister losing to larry
owings losing
wrestling from the olympics all of these
tragedies
of various forms
so that's the ioc there's politics
and you're sort of being very pragmatic
but stepping back
wrestling is one of the oldest forms of
combat period
dating back there's cave drawings 15
thousand years ago
and if you look at uh the ancient
olympics the greek olympics twenty seven
hundred years ago
did you ever when you wrestled or
coached do you now
see wrestling in this way a freestyle
folk style wrestling
the purity of sort of two human beings
locked
in combat the the roots of that us just
human beings
this fair struggle between two men or
two women
i don't think i ever looked at it
as anything but just to a combat
and
i think there's times that have made me
figure out how to make that combat
better
there's little markers or little
points in time in your life that make
you
wonder or i should say determined
to be able to get more out of yourself
and to be able to take it to a new level
and i don't think people can actually
feel that way unless you've actually
had a lot of accomplishments in anything
i think there's anything out there i
mean no matter what sport
or or breaking the four minute mile i
mean when you broke that
when they broke that roger banister
broke that four minute mile
i can't imagine him breaking it from his
best time being 4
30. you know it's one of these things
that
along the line there that he did
had some close calls or
he had some coaching that was given him
the opportunity to become a little
better
but i think because he was doing well
and being very successful that the
opportunity came
and so as for me it's like the same
thing i had so much
success and so many
practices that went well
and so much goodness out of this sport
that it gave me the opportunity
to really look more finite
and look more how i can even make it
better and so it's like
if you look at my library upstairs i got
a library upstairs
and there's a lot of books up there
from the family and but if you look at
the gable books up there
i got a lot of russian technique books
i can't read the book but i can see the
diagrams
and i can see this the figures they
don't really show it in pictures
they do it in drawings and
and so it's like when i was trying to
beat the best
that has labeled the best because
they win the world championships every
year since they've
been just about involved and i don't
think they got started involved until
like the 50s but
but you know it's something you know you
study
the best who's out there but then you
don't focus
so much on the best that you can't beat
the best
you learn from them but there's
something that they don't have
that you can have toughness to technique
to the art to the science yeah all that
stuff and that's why
even talking to you when you're sitting
over there you love mit
and you're bragging about it over
harvard you know
you know it's because it's true in your
eyes and
and that's and that's great and it might
be but uh but
it's the same type of thing that uh
you know there's something that you're
probably stealing from harvard yeah but
you won't give them credit well then in
the interest of time
uh i've read that you're pretty serious
you're
pretty seriously into fishing so what's
the biggest fish you ever caught
what are we talking about here are we
you're talking about no
i don't think i've ever caught a big
ocean fish i'm not i'm a river lake
fisherman
i have trout no probably uh
probably northern okay i probably caught
a northern that weighed
20 some pounds uh you know i
my fish i like to catch is walleyes and
that the reason why i like to catch them
because they're
really good eating fish and the best
eating fish are not the real big ones
uh you know it's kind of kind of
interesting they
i got people hunting deer right on my
land and
they're looking for the big bucks but
they're not the best eaters if you want
if you want to eat them
but they're the best trophy so you know
i do have a couple trophy walleyes on
the wall but
but uh most time i throw the big ones
back and put them back in there
so i don't know if you know there's a
book by hemingway called old man in the
sea
and part of it and uh ernest hemingway
ernest hemingway yeah
and he uh there's a there's an old man
that basically uh
catches an 18-footer but it can't pull
it in doesn't have the strength so they
together spend
while the sharks eat away at it i mean
this is very powerful
story i think one in the nobel prize but
he says
it's better to be lucky the old man says
it's better to be lucky
but i would rather be exact that that
that way when luck comes you're ready so
let me ask
uh what do you think about luck
do you believe in free will that we have
actions
that control the direction destination
of our life or does
luck and some other outside forces
really land you where you end up
for me i'm not about luck but i do
think there is luck is involved
but i think it's mostly created uh
just how lucky you are through
preparations
and things happen things have happened
in my life
forever and a lot of good things
and a lot of people could say hey you've
been pretty lucky to win all these
awards
i don't know if you analyze my life
i don't think it was involved with luck
you know i think it was more involved
with preparation
and you know and again science had you
been smarter
had you understood that you could do
some things
and be just as lucky that'd be great but
i'm only as smart
as today so when i was training
in my life and me even training people
in my life
as of that moment that's how lucky i am
to uh
be able to um have whatever is available
to me
and that's what you call that a lot of
science so for me i
i think that uh you know like right now
if i look back
i do a lot of things different just
because
things are proven differently like i'd
give people water during practice and i
did
and i would let them change their
running wrestling shoes into running
shoes to run sprints on the concrete
or i would actually maybe um maybe i had
a guy climb 12 ropes after practice
one after another and then maybe the
next day i'd do it again
ah you know i might not make him do it
the next day i might
let him recover a little bit more and
uh you got to learn keep adding to
your philosophy and your philosophy may
have been great at that time
but it's at that time and what is really
important
is where you at with this time today
and so there's better ways to do things
now if you ever take attitude out of it
and just depend on total science
then you know you're not going to be as
as uh you know i think it's i i listened
to a couple of
people that are really pretty famous
people uh
one of them was john irving he was a
writer yeah
and he told me he said you think i
really
learned how to be a great writer in uh
writing school i
he said yeah i learned a lot there but
really what gave me the ability
to stay focused just to work extra hours
to be more disciplined
was wrestling practices that's right he
was a wrestler
yeah yeah he goes i go back to that
that's what gave me that chance
you know and and there's a guy in iowa
that uh
a guy named norman borlaug he uh
he he learned he he invented a process
to feed
the underprivileged countries of the
world
and he was a wrestler and he said the
same thing and he worked
extremely hard and he said i give a lot
of credit to the sport of wrestling
and even though i was i'm known for this
and i got a statue in
in washington dc because i saved a
billion lives
plus uh i'm gonna give wrestling a lot
of credit
so you know i think some of these
mma stars and some of these guys
that maybe weren't wrestlers that had to
wrestle russell
had to fight wrestling guys and stuff
missed a little bit there
but i think the ones that did have
wrestling probably have a really good
chance and can adapt to the other ones
but you know i think every martial art
or every activity is
good and you probably can't skip any but
i don't think they're ever going to
overlook and say that wrestling's
pretty not are not valuable because
it is however that doesn't mean you're
going to make it you still got to take
the values and apply it
whatever area you're going to be in and
and some people forget that
some people can't get over
the highness of getting your arm raised
in a wrestling match
and i and you know what what's even
greater than
me getting my arm raised is that i if
i'm a coach or if i doesn't belong with
you
that you get your arm raised yeah and
even if you don't get your arm raised
it's what you walk away with
and how and how you learn to uh
handle that as well because there's
going to be some losses but you don't
want many
because you don't want to get used to
losing i can tell you that that's the
hunger for the win
it's the brotherhood the sisterhood of
the wrestling room
and it's hard work and science that's
going to be luck
at the end of the day absolutely that
luck you know
i'm you know i i like luck but i think
it's created by uh
the opportunity that you make your luck
you make your luck yeah
dan it was a huge honor thank you for
welcoming me into your home and for
having this conversation yeah no problem
good man thanks for listening to this
conversation with dan gable
and thank you to our sponsors trial labs
a machine learning company
expressvpn grammarly writing helper tool
and simply save home security so the
choice
is artificial intelligence privacy
grammar
or safety choose wisely my friends and
if you wish
click the sponsor links below to get a
discount and to support this podcast
and now let me leave you with some words
from dan gable
the first period is won by the best
technician
the second period is won by the kid in
the best shape
and the third period is won by the kid
with the biggest heart
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time